hello and welcome to the week 11 Bach
report fix football show presented by
State Farm my name is Adam Levitan of
establish the run.com as always joined
by Michael Leon of establish the run.com
on today's show we're gonna be going
over some players in week 11 that we
would not be excited to start AKA Fades
Michael has shaved gotten a haircut
looks like a Human Instead of a vampire
like normally looks Michael how's it
going
today uh you know I had to do some
self-care this week after that torturous
Bill's loss so that's that's where we're
at yes Mike was actually at the game and
he was the 12th man on the field
actually and he got the flag which cost
the bills the game let some more people
get in here before we get into our Fades
of the week before we do though a couple
of questions from chat we always love
our good friends in the chat here
Bleacher Report first question is a good
good one for you Leone from Tom Brady
it's amazing you know Tom Brady Hall of
Fame quarterback formerly married to
super model he's in here chatting with
us he says what are your thoughts on
dlan concade this week we of course have
the offensive coordinator change for
Leone's bills this week any thoughts on
cancade now that Joe Brady will be
calling plays for the
bills yeah I mean I don't know if his
role will really change dramatically but
I think that's fine for concade since he
missed that game with concussion he's
had Target shares of 20% 18% 29%
23% and you know at the tight end
position you just don't see that type of
volume on a week- toe basis so I think
he's one of the top tight end starters
week in and week out I think the Bill's
offense ultimately is going to perform
better than it has and you know it's a
tough matchup against the Jets but I do
think it'll Force Allen into some
shorter aot higher completion right
throws and that's where concade kind of
thrives one more question from chat
before we get into today's Fades young
Stunna says Terry
McClaren or Drake London you know I
still think Terry mclen is very good
it's good that Sam Howell and Eric benmy
are trying to turn this team or have
turned this team into Chiefs East what's
not good for Terry mclen is they're
throwing to literally eight nine 10 guys
on a weekly basis which
is insane and I mean they're not
highlighting mclen or Dodson at all
London of course has its own S as part
of an extremely run-heavy and
quarterback depraved Falcons team so
what do you think about that one Leon
mclen or Drake London this
week yeah I think I'm going to lean
McLaren I think Washington's going to be
able to put up points this week um
against the Giants they have such a bad
defense bad team overall and sometimes
you'd be concerned with a pass catcher
in that environment but we saw Dallas
just torch them through the air and
Washington like Dallas did I think is
going to be throw heavy despite the fact
that they're favorites in this this game
and will'll probably be leading
throughout they are you know weak in and
week Out Among the league leaders and
pass right over expectations so I just
like the efficiency upside a bit more
for uh for McLaren and Atlanta you know
they've had their struggles
offensively one more quick question here
from Ryan pelman says thoughts on puka
nikua or Isaiah Pacho this week so just
from a game plan perspective I expect
the Chiefs to have a very throw heavy
game plan they always have a throw heavy
game plan but when you the Eagles the
clear way to beat them right now is by
throwing the football Corners have
really struggled with speed and so I
think that we'll see a lot of momes drop
backs not as many Pacho runs here PUK on
the other hand gets Matthew Stafford
back which I think is a big win for him
so I think that's pretty easily puka
over Pacho for me Leon any disagreement
there no no disagreement I have to know
I was a little throwing on the McClaren
London question and I'm correct that
Atlanta does not play this week so I
hope hopefully you're starting M I'm
guessing that rest of season so I'll
still go mcen rest of season there oh my
gosh we've hit rock bottom we don't we
didn't even we didn't even flag that
Drake London wasn't playing this week go
don't tell the people at State Farm
we're gonna get fired
okay let's go
to you know what let's get into the
Fades so these are players who we think
will underperform their normal baselines
this week for whatever reason could be
matchup could be someone else returns to
the lineup could be all kinds of things
let's start with number one fade of the
week and that is Amari Cooper lot of bad
vibes around Amari Cooper and the Browns
right now because deshun Watson is going
to be out for the rest of the season due
to shoulder surgery I thought they'd go
back to PJ Walker they have decided not
to do that and Mark's had some moments
with PJ Walker they're going to Dorian
Thompson Robinson rookie out of UCLA now
Dorian Thompson Robinson had some huge
preseason games and looked really good
he was full in his first NFL start last
time he filled in for Deshawn Watson so
maybe I'm overreacting here to the
quarterback stuff Leone because I I do
like to just bet on wide receiver talent
but man this is scary for Amari Cooper I
think any thoughts on him this
week yeah I don't think you're
overreacting I mean we have an extremely
low total game here with Pittsburgh um I
think Cleveland's actually favored
despite just having a 17 team total so
the total in this game is 33 the
Cleveland defense is so good Pittsburgh
offense struggles where you know one
like Cleveland's not going to throw the
ball as much as they did before given
the quarterback change but two they
don't really have any incentive to this
week with the way their defense can
Dominate and keep them in the game keep
this close so I just think it's gonna be
so run heavy you're going to see reduced
volume for Amari Cooper you're probably
going to see reduced efficiency on the
targets that he does get um you know I'm
not burying him totally for the rest of
the season we'll see what DRT can do but
I for this week I I want to see it first
I'm going to put him on my bench and and
go from there there agreed okay stick in
that game for our second fade of the
week and that is Mr Naji Harris now I
don't want people to overreact to this
whole starters thing and if you guys
aren't deep on Twitter with us uh
following all this stuff you might not
even be aware of this but Mike Tomlin
came out and said that Jaylen Warren was
announced as the with the starters
because he's earned it I don't think
that's that big a deal they also
announced Alan Robinson as a starter
this past week instead of George Pickins
when we know that's not that big a deal
what is a big deal though is that Jaylen
Warren continues to outplay niji Harris
and as we saw last week you can get
Warren ahead at times in usage so I
understand Naj had a good game last week
this week he plays the Browns and he's
dealing with Rising Jaylen Warren pretty
easy sit I think for me here Leon
assuming you have someone comparable
what do you think about the nji warrren
situation right
now yeah Naji is just going to be very
game script dependent I mean I liked him
a lot last week against Green Bay where
I thought it was going to be a close
game I thought he would see the field a
bit more he went 16 for 82 one of his
more efficient games he has had
touchdowns in three of four games but
those have been victories with the team
playing you know ahead in most of those
spots and again against Cleveland it's
going to be tight so I think they can
try to run with him but what we saw in
the first match against Cleveland is
this team against a really good defense
just get some bad down and distances and
that's where Jaylen Warren is going to
play the touchdown Equity is a lot lower
than it's been the past several weeks so
I agree with you he's a sit this
week all right let's go back to chat
actually for a little bit here
appreciate all of you hanging out today
on this beautiful Thursday ahead of a
big Ravens Bengals Thursday night game
I'm actually excited for Billy Stevens
says Keaton Mitchell I'm starting him
I'm not sure what the question is here
uh Billy but uh you know the KE Mitchell
projection is a hard one I think if I
was in charge of the Ravens I would just
be like it's enough with Justice Hill
we're going to go with Gus Edwards as
our Thunder and Keen Mitchell as our
lightning I don't think it's crazy to
think that the Ravens might come to that
conclusion but I don't know that we can
actually project that so how do you
think the running back split tonight
goes Leone between Gus Edwards Keaton
Mitchell and Mr Justice
Hill yeah it's difficult we do kind of
have Baltimore trying to lean into the
run a bit here when you look at the way
to attack Cincinnati they're a little
bit more prone to giving up you know
efficient plays on the ground than they
are through the air but it is also a
tighter spread than Baltimore usually
plays and it's only three and a half
point spread and that might kind of
cancel out and lead to more pass
attempts so you're really banking on the
efficiency from Ken Mitchell I know you
might have heard that at times with like
Devon aan the beginning of the season I
think this Situation's a little bit
different than that situation uh I would
start him I guess we just talked about n
as a fade like that's a good litmus test
um I don't know how you feel Adam on
Keon versus N I might take the blind
swing on the upside from Keon there but
that's that's about my threshold like
anybody better than n I'm probably too
scared of the volume uh concerns with
Kon yeah I mean it's not really the way
I play fantasy is to bet on guys to
average 10 yards a carry right that's
just not the way I play because every
time you think you have an outlier
there's hundreds of them for every
Tyreek Hill for every Devon hen there's
hundreds of them that end up to be total
dust so it's not the way I normally play
Fantasy but God I really hate this spot
for Naji so I might actually consider
that I baban says is it time to drop
George
Pickins they don't have any interest in
diversifying George Pickins route tree
when Deontay Johnson is out there I
would like to know who you're dropping
him for George Pickins I would like to
know who uh else is on your bench but if
you're in a thin league and you've had
enough I do not have a problem with it
I'm not sure it's going to get much
better Keon we just gave our take on Gus
Edwards Dy says Raheem moer or Joe Mixon
tonight so most of course gonna be
dealing with Mr Anan coming back however
they are playing the Raiders this week
whereas Mixon is playing the
Ravens I'm just
a last year two years I believe Joe
mixon's reached 20 fantasy points one
time I just feel like when I sit Jo Joe
Mixon I'm not losing out of that much I
know he had a five touchdown game in
there I just feel like he rarely gives
me the blade he he rarely crushes me if
I sit him it would be moer here for me
but yeah Leon what do you think about
Mixon versus
moer I think it's moster Miami has a 30
team total it's the highest on the week
that's like nine points higher than the
Bengals that's a huge discrepancy you
know in projections they're going to be
pretty close because mixon's G to get
you you know a few dump off catches
right like especially in full PPR he's
going to get you like four for 20 on the
ground and it it's gonna you know you've
mentioned his lack of ceiling but he
almost always gets you double digit
points in some way gets his way there so
um he's gonna project fine but yeah I'm
swinging for the fences like usually
your fantasy matchup on a weekly basis
isn't going to be swung by like Mixon
scoring 12 and mostard scoring 10 it's
be swung by mostard breaking off a
couple long runs scoring 22 and 25 and
Mixon being there at 12 like that's a
bigger difference and he has bigger
potential to be impactful on your
matchup from shtino says Devonte Adams
or Rashid rice this week man Devonte
Adams is down bad I mean we're talking
about sitting Devonte Adams in favor of
a third round rookie who does not even
play more than I don't know 60% of the
routes is what I would expect for Rashid
rice here this week of course it is a
very good matchup for Mr rice but God I
couldn't imagine sitting Devonte Adams
for him Leone what do you think
I'm I'm team Devonte Adams here the
first two weeks with Pierce is the
interim head coach too they've had like
really soft opponents as particularly
offensively in the Giants and the Jets
and they've been able to straight
establish it but Devonte Adams had a 48%
Target share last week uh that game
against Miami they're gonna have to
throw and that's just I mean we could
very easily see Devonte Adams and double
digit plus Target so I'm I'm taking that
volume over rice Eric suits says tank
Dell or Tyler Boyd this week we are
expecting Nico Collins back I think from
his injury however Robert Woods is
banged up now so we still have a lot to
chew on there with our Texans wide
receiver projection of course we need to
make this call tonight because the
Bengals do play and we do know that t
Higgins is indeed out which has
certainly been a win for Tyler Boyd
dropped a touchdown last week but man
can't deny that tank Dell and CJ Strat
have something serious going on here
Leon this is a tough one what do you
think
it is tough boys should see a ton of
volume I think like short ADOT stuff but
once again I'm I'm sort of compelled to
go the higher cealing play you've got
higher total Dome game between Arizona
and Houston Dell has been remarkable
downfield they've even gotten him some
enzone looks and manufactured those
despite his size recently I know he
didn't have a lot of those out of the
gate so I'll side with Dell and the
bigger play potential even though you
know Boyd probably does have a higher
catch
floor all right ACC Kim Bron has the
same problem that I've seen from a lot
of people this week they're sharp they
have Sam lorta they're sharp they have
Mark Andrews they're sharp they have
some good tight end and because they're
sharp they also have Trey McBride and
now they have a problem because they
don't want to start or can't start two
tight ends my recommendation would be to
trade one of them either McBride or
leaport and try to get some help around
the rest of your team so you don't have
to make this decision and carry two
tight ends every week but anyways I
digress Leone what do you think this
week about leaport vers McBride straight
up our projections that establish the
Run have these like deadlocked at 14
full PPR points between the two very
similar just over 11 points and half PPR
but our ceiling projections you know
they side the way of Sam leaport and
that comes with more touchdown equity
for this Detroit Lions offense and I
kind of agree with our model there I'll
go leaport on ceiling I think it's kind
of a toss up on median
projection all right let's get back to
our Fades here this week we already hit
Amari Cooper we already hit Naji Harris
Let's Move next to our third fade which
is going to be Mr Gabe Davis now Gabe
Davis is very volatile player I thought
with Dawson knocks out maybe they would
make his role less volatile they have
not done so and I feel like the failures
of Gabe have way more to do with
whatever Bill's offensive struggles you
think there are than Ken dorsy right
like if you could have fired Gabe Davis
I would have rather fired Gabe Davis
than Ken dorsy of course you cannot fire
gabee Davis but anyways very difficult
match up for Gabe Davis this week really
hard to see him winning against his Jets
pass defense in my opinion he's just not
good enough so I think pretty simple
fade there on Gabe Davis Leon do you
want to come to the aid of your bills
Brothers at all here on Gabe
Davis no I think you know I like concade
this week because I think they're gonna
be forcing the short ADOT stuff that's
not really what Gabe does with the
exception of like that one random week
his games against the Jets the last two
seasons is like two for 30 three uh
three for 31 last year and then this
year he had another two for 32 and I
just think that's the type of for
performance you're likely to see yeah
sure maybe he gets lucky and catches a
long one but um not the not the matchup
that's going to increase that likelihood
floor is very low for
Gabe um agreed similarly a much better
version of Gabe like an actual Hall of
Fame caliber version of Gabe is our next
fade and that would be Mr Mike Evans now
people are going to say how can you guys
fade Mike Evans has been playing so well
I I think my biggest concern on Mike
Evans this week is this bucks offensive
line trying to protect against a 49ers
defensive line which is so talented now
I know the 49ers defensive line has not
yet gotten to the top or really anywhere
near the top in a lot of these pass
rushing categories I think they'll end
there by the end of the year given the
talent and scheme that they have and so
when Mike Evans needs two three four
seconds to get downfield that's a
problem when Baker is under a lot of
pressure so I think an interesting fade
this week is Mike Evans I know he's been
having an awesome year this might be a
controversial one Leon any thoughts on
the Bucks 49ers game here in Mike
Evans I uh touted some Jacksonville
Jaguars receivers last week because the
49ers defense hasn't been that great and
then uh we saw them dominate the Jags
and now in fn's dvoa they're up to
seventh in pass defense so they're
turning that around pretty quickly like
you said the the defense line has a lot
of talent I'm still probably a little
bit more bullish on Evans than you are
we've got him ranked with like DK meta
Debo Samuel mares Brown types this week
just because we're expecting Tampa Bay
to have to throw a lot against San
Francisco but there's certainly routes
where the whole offense shuts down and
there's just not fantasy points for
anyone this
week uh let's go back to the chat CK
plays says do I start Calvin Ridley so
it's tough to answer this question
without knowing who else you would start
I think the concern on Calvin Ridley is
real though there's a lot of data out
there that he is not getting open at the
same rate that he once did that that and
his last year in Atlanta even before the
suspension he wasn't even that good at
production or getting open he's also
being pinned to the sideline where
Christian Kirk is getting more of the
layup easy targets and you see that
reflected in Target share and catch rate
so yeah I get it it's scary uncount
Ridley right now I'm not sure you have
someone better to put in your lineup
than him when he's home against the
Titans though so yeah how concerned are
you on the Ridley stuff right now Leon
we're we're a long way from watching
Kelvin Ridley training camps uh against
nobody really inspiring us to take him
in the second and third round um that
that got wild uh I I felt some victim to
that especially after the first week
when he came out like crazy I do think
you know if there is a get right spot
it's probably this against the Tennessee
defense that's really good against the
run and really bad against the pass and
I think the boundary wide receivers here
get a little bit of a bump more than
usual so probably would say to start
Calvin Ridley in most leagues this week
I know it's been
frustrating last chat before we get back
to our Fades here comes from Casey
Hawkins says should I start Logan Thomas
or Luke
Musgrave this week Logan Thomas or Luke
Musgrave so like man there's been a lot
of late tight end breakouts this year
obviously leapor and Trey McBride come
to mind quickly I don't mind streaming
through guys like this and typically
when I T think about these kind of
decisions it's just who do I think is
more likely to score a touchdown
commanders are home against this Giants
team I think it would probably be Logan
Thomas for me even though I understand
the Chargers have one of the worst pass
defense in the league also so what do
you think about
lt3 versus Luke Musgrave
Leone yeah I'd go with Logan Thomas and
not only is he more likely to score a
touchdown but despite the fact that
Green Bay are small underdogs here and
Washington are pretty decent favorites
we still have Washington throwing more
based on like the kind of identity of
these teams and how they operate so more
volume and more touchdown Equity um you
know I'm not thrilled to start either
from I want to say it's a huge gap but I
feel pretty good sliding with LT over
Musgrave all right enough's enough we
need to get to our
bundles right now we're going to jump
into our fantasy
bundles presented by State Farm where
bundling your home and auto insurance is
just a another way to save with the
personal price
plan bundles are going to be teammates
that we think fit well together if any
of you guys have played DFS you play DFS
tournaments that's kind of our specialty
at establish the run if you are
interested in playing you need to
understand stacking very well players
that correlate well together first
bundle we like this week is Jaylen Herz
to Devonte Smith now I know Devonte
Smith has been absolutely run C around
by AJ Brown for much of this season
however not expecting to see Dallas Gard
in this game and when we've seen that in
the past there have been big bumps to
the usage and roll for Devonte Smith
Eagles gonna have to throw the ball a
lot and be very aggressive against the
Chiefs on Monday night and what I think
could be a Super Bowl preview so that's
the first one there Leone second one is
a bit more off the board for us if you
want to talk about our second
bundle yeah our second bundle is Josh
dobs the TJ hackinson here this Sunday
night game for the Minnesota Vikings
against Denver at this point in time we
think Justin Jefferson's still gonna sit
out another week and we saw hackinson
last week there was a report before the
game that his snaps would be limited
they were he was down to 63% snap share
usually in the mid 80s but uh Adam it
didn't matter he had a 44% Target share
absolutely dominated and you know
quickly becoming dbs's favorite Target
right now they also dobs his first full
week of practice they had a positive
pass R over expectation they threw a
decent bit despite leading most of this
game and he's a very capable quarterback
does a lot with his legs so a little bit
more fantasy upside here than you
probably think at first glance third
bundle is a return to health Matthew
Stafford to Cooper cup and I know this
one sounds really easy I don't think
people realize the upside that there is
every week when Matthew Stafford takes
the field healthy and Cooper cup takes
the field healthy these guys have the
potential to break records every single
week we saw them do it in 2021 we saw
him do it for the first half of 2022
facing the Seahawks this week isn't like
the best possible matchup but coming out
of the Buy to me is the time to play
this bundle Stafford Cup pukan niua this
is the time to play this now as they
come out of the buy and if they lose
more games and they're three and six
right now I'll start to be worried that
they are actually going to want to play
out the string here for a really bad
Rams team so I'm hopeful for anybody out
there best ball bags or whatever
Stafford cup play well and get a win
this week I think that they
will only I'll go with our fourth bundle
here Brock pie to Brandon auk for the
49ers was a disappointing week for auk
last week with Debo Samuel back had his
lowest Target share of the season but it
was just his first game under 20% Target
Sharon ultimately not too too worried
about Debo being back just because auk's
been so absurd his yards per Target this
season up to 12.3 which is like a crazy
number and yeah it'll probably regress a
little bit but if there there's an
offense that's going to beat efficiency
numbers in the past game in San
Francisco going up against the Tampa Bay
defense that you know much like
Tennessee talked about earlier a lot
better against the Run than against the
pass so um I think I's gonna have to be
efficient here but it is a good spot for
him to continue to do
so Fifth and final bundle this week is
GNA be Tu aoka vioa to Jaylen Wadd I
know what people are thinking oh they're
playing the Raiders at home they're
going to kill them there's no there's no
uh uh volume coming this is what people
said last week about Dak when he went
for 400 yards you know this is what
people said about Patrick Mahomes when
he played the Jets couple years ago and
he went absolutely nuclear and so I
think people in fantasy football
specifically overrate the blowout aspect
of games if the Dolphins score 30 points
in this game which I think they will Tua
is gonna have a lot to do with it Jaylen
wad also should as guy's finally coming
back healthy I think he's been playing
through a lot of things banged up
bruised and nicked for much of the year
and Jaylen wad is a much better player I
think than what he's shown so far so Tua
to Jaylen wad there in that home game
against the
Raiders all right let's finish up our
Fades here we had Amari we had Naji
Harris we had Gabe Davis we had Mike
Evans our fifth fade is going to be Mr
Antonio Gibson now I know Antonio
Gibson's on injury report this week with
a toe issue I'm not sure he's going to
end up playing I kind of think that he
will but if he ends up playing I'm not
sure how much he'll be used because when
you face Tommy DeVito and this Giants
offensive line and Giants team you can
get big leads and that's something that
I think the commanders will do and when
they get leads they go to Brian Robinson
they do not go to Antonio Gibson and so
if you think you can project the game
Flow here it's a really good Brian
Robinson spot and a really bad Antonio
Gibson
spot man Brian Robinson last weekly only
the receiving game too Alpha I'm
interested in Robinson this week I think
a lot of other people will be
too sets up as a Brian Robinson smash
spot for sure if you kind of just even
glance through Washington's schedule
beginning of the year they had a couple
wins against Arizona Denver some weaker
opponents and we only saw Gibson with
like two or three Rush attempts you know
two or three Targets in those games
whereas recently in some of these like
back and forth games he's been getting
like five catches a week so that's going
to go away um and then we got another
running back for a 6-1 deont foran this
is another spot where there's injury
news to consider and that is Cle Herbert
looks like he's gonna be back for the
Bears and Adam I we actually kind of
think Herbert's gonna immediately sort
of step in and be ahead of Foreman at
the very least it's probably gonna be a
pretty tight split and you know with
Fields likely back too I think that
might actually like limit the high value
Touches for the running back somewhat
big time Big Time big time I don't think
people realize how much worse Fields is
for the running backs than Tyson bent
even though Fields is a better
quarterback than Tyson bent all right
that's going to do it for our Fades once
again they were Amari Cooper these are
week 11 Fades Amari Cooper Nashi Harris
Gabe Davis Mike Evans Antonio Gibson and
Mr Dante
Forman all right we got about five
minutes here we'll fire off as many
questions as we possibly can oh Eddie
Anthony's got a good question he says
should I bench Tony Pard again it's
really hard to know if we should be
benching guys we don't know who we're
benching them for the people have had
enough with Tony po Leon and by people I
mean me so uh what do you think about
Tony Pard this week here against the
Carolina Panthers one of the worst
defenses in the entire
NFL I mean I'm I'm starting to Cave here
on the Tony par love Edie's trolling me
a bit but there's some you know
beginning of the year it seemed like he
was you know not efficient running a
little bit bad but it would turn around
now we're starting to see Rico do mix in
a little bit they even made a note of
like maybe getting him more touches and
since the bye they've gone fullon pass
game on slau like their three highest
pass right over expectation games since
the start of last season are the last
three weeks and I don't see that
changing but God I'm not benching him
against Carolina I'm not playing him
every week just to miss the game against
Carolina where their run defense is bad
the game Scripts going to be great I I
also feel like you know narrative Street
here that squeaky wheel they got to get
him a touchdown right like they just
they just gota so I'm sarting so he was
six Ines short of a touchdown two
separate times last week the week before
actually scored a touchdown and it
didn't count because the offensive
lineman did not report to the referee as
he should have so I I'm given up hope on
Tony Pard like explosive huge games I
have not given up hope on Tony Pard SC
scoring two touchdowns against the
Carolina Panthers like but yeah it's
going to be I think more of a touchdown
bet than people think Angel young says
is Courtland Sutton a good start this
week man cour Sutton's been playing well
really well and I actually think that
better than Jerry Judy and I didn't not
think that was gonna happen at the
beginning of the year I thought Jerry
Jud is just a straightup better player
at this point it's hard for me to sit
Corin Su dude is just playing well and
and the Broncos are playing well I would
have no problem whatsoever starting
courin Sutton Leon any thoughts on that
one
yeah I still can't believe courland Su
caught that ball on Monday night against
my bills uh dragging dragging those Toes
that was absolutely remarkable but yeah
I think I think he's pretty much a start
you know we've got him and like the
Chris Godwin rashy rice Jordan Addison
sort of tier this week just to give you
guys some names where we have sudden
ranked MTM asks Godwin or theelen this
week man that's that's kind of a tough
one on feel I kind of like Godwin a
little bit more because I think Carolina
could get destroyed but the numbers for
us have theing projecting a couple
points better especially if you're in
full PPR just because he gets these low
ADOT you know they're playing from
behind negative game script and he just
racks up some catches I think some of
those ceiling games he had are a bit
fluky but Flor should remain pretty well
for theen whereas Godwin's like
similarly sort of like low ad out High
catch rate but he's competing with Mike
Evans yep exactly uh luchano says Drome
Ford or Devon aain l man if you were
holding uh Anan through this entire
four-week iron and now he's cleared and
healthy to play the Raiders I think you
got to start him man I I think you just
got to get hen right back in there I
wouldn't overthink that one jdl says who
do I bench out of auk Devonte or Garrett
Wilson and so of course this would be a
hard harder question if they had any
other quarterback besides Zach Wilson I
still think Zach Wilson would probably
be enough for me to bench Garrett Wilson
here Leone any thoughts on that one and
then you can go to the next
one man yeah that's that's a tough one
but I'm probably Bening Garrett Wilson
on the QB concern on the Anan thing real
quick too like the dudes played three
meaningful games and scored like 30 plus
fantasy points in all of them I mean at
this point you're just starting him
until he fouls I mean we can keep it
simple there with aan but lowly asked
Daryl Henderson or khil Herbert this
week um I kind of think Henderson I
think a pretty good spot I think there's
too much risk I think there's too much
risk that that Herbert comes in behind
Deontay Foreman you know I I don't know
exactly how they're going to play it the
Bears running back but Fields is
probably going to score a rushing
touchdown if they get close and I I just
think there's too much risk with her but
I I would go de hendo there cucumber
says Kyler Murray or Joe burrow so er
was excited about Kyler after they saw
that crazy run that he made in that uh
in that game in his first game back um
Joe burrow of course is going to drop
back tonight probably 40 plus times
matchup is brutal any thoughts on this
one Leone Kyler versus Joe
burrow I mean I think it's a bit of a
coin flip honestly I think most weeks
it's gonna be pretty clearly burrow but
the Ravens defense is so so good that uh
I'd be fine going either way our
projections do slightly favor Kyler
Murray with a bit more Rush upside
normally burrow would out project him so
much in the past game that it wouldn't
matter you still start burrow but
because of the matchup that gets closer
and yeah tiebreaker goes to Murray's
legs Sean sorbin says David and joku or
Cole KT so again David and joku is gonna
have Dorian Thompson Robinson at
quarterback Cole KT will have Justin
Fields as his quarterback the way
they've been using David and joku has
not been great it's been decent volume
but a lot of it's been screens and like
little hitches it's just just a weird
way in my opinion to use David and joku
um but yeah what do you think about this
one yeah um I think in joku is involved
enough in the screen game that in some
ways he's insulated a little bit more
than Amari Cooper is from the
quarterback play so some positivity for
in joku there Gabe eay asks burrow
tonight or Fields basically the same
answer as the Kyler one you know I think
most weeks the passing discrepancy will
favor burrow but this week in particular
I'm GNA side with the legs and the
rushan upside for Justin Fields all
right last question we are going to do
here on this beautiful Thursday
afternoon evening it comes from Zack
Brittain says James Connor or Noah Brown
in his Flex so I'm little worried about
this Noah Brown injury Mis practice
Wednesday Mis practice Thursday and he
he's also dealing with Robert Woods
being back tank Dell playing well and
Nico Collins presumably being back as
well meanwhile James Conor stepped right
back into that really good usage that he
always had seems to get whenever he's
healthy for the Cardinals my gut says
James Conor here but I would want to see
the health status around all these
Texans wide receivers first but yeah any
take on that one Leone let's assume that
Noah Brown is healthy any take on that
one yeah I think I slightly will go the
way of James Conor just with the wide
receiver room for the Texans getting a
bit more crowded and Conor immediately
saw 70% of the designed run is for
Arizona last week that could bump up his
second week back and um yeah I think
it's a pretty good spot overall I mean
it's a good spot for both of them but um
I think the uncertainty factors favor
Connor a bit more than brown this week
all right that is going to do it for the
week 11 Bleacher Report fan football
show presented by our great friends at
State Farm if you're serious about
fantasy football and you want to get
more serious first you need to be on
Twitter
Adam Levitan Michael Leone establish the
Run of course I assume you're already
following Bleacher Report and then also
if you want to be real hardcore and be
real serious can check out our site
where we never leave our house look at
Leoni we never leave all we do is work
on fish football all day for Le for
everybody behind the scenes at State
Farm for everybody behind the scenes at
Bleacher Reports I am Adam we will see
you probably next week before
Thanksgiving good luck
everybody